[Music]
International chess professionals
converge in st. Louis for the 2017
spring chess classic today was the
penultimate day of play in the 2017
spring chess classic and while it's
still closed there are no champions yet
today Sam seve on could have clinched
Group C had he won his game tomorrow may
be his day players like yarrow zerah
book were especially exhausted after
their long games and they need to rest
up because tomorrow the round starts two
hours early
and if playoffs occur some of the
competitors could be playing into the
evening more than one game the 2017
spring chess classic features a combined
prize fund of more than 50 grand win the
top prize in Group A that will get you
$6,000 $4,000 is the prize for Group B
and the top prize for Group C is $5,000
that's because Group C is actually
stronger than Group B on our second to
last day in Group A Yaroslav 0 bucks
comes away with a win against Alexander
eepa top and you said you were
determined to win today tell us about
what you were thinking going in yeah I
just really wanted to take revenge for
the Winter Classic tournaments I mean I
lost was black and I mean I was I was
better at that game but somehow in time
trouble I just collapsed and was kind of
painful loss yeah so I really wanted to
win today you know just to make it even
I mean I guess it would be kind of fair
you know it's good that we already have
our classic series rivalries going yeah
so I mean especially my previous two
games were not really tiring or
something so I accumulated the energy
you know
investors today in today's game so yeah
well let's take a look at the game you
had the white pieces here a4 looks very
active but it just looks so probably not
the best move since I'm actually
weakening my B 3 square and I'm giving
some like squares for penetration for
black some I mean somewhere later so you
know it looks active but I probably
should have played just something
different maybe just like h4 or
something like that yeah and then and
then yeah and then here at g5 was a
really good move by him and I got a
little bit frustrated be honest I
thought draw is coming and I didn't want
to make a draw yet but here here
actually he actually made a mistake we
should be g7 is clearly not the best
move I mean at least in my opinion
I thought the easiest way for him to
play just would be 97 and the point is
he's trying to trade the pawn on f4
twice and then like he has a square on
e5 and I thought it just equal I mean
maybe I'm still slightly better in a bit
better but nothing special at all that
was my opinion yeah like here if I go at
5 then I don't know like probably I'm
not even pushing for a win anymore but
if I'm taking here then his knight goes
to f6 Bishop to g7 and seems like it has
some kind of play I mean I I thought it
maybe I can do something like this
Knight goes 5 but it seems like he
always can trade them after 94 and yeah
probably heart went really hard to 1 for
white but after Bishop g7 I an a5 he
actually started blundering here because
he got into time trouble so and like
kind of exploited it so I mean a5 a5 is
a weird move kind of I thought it's
really weird
more like well Bishop that's that's what
Bishop g7 actually triggers kind of
because then he's like oh I need to put
a knight on the sound somehow he doesn't
he doesn't want me to allow a5 but still
he could have played Bishop e8 here and
I'm not sure if I have that much I mean
well it could be a little bit better but
not much high five
I was really surprised with this move I
mean in a good way surprised and then
yeah and then I just won the pawn
probably missed Queen d2 here and the
pawn on d5 is hanging and then I thought
this position should be close to winning
I mean his knight on d4 looks active but
then if I just regroup my pieces if I
just put the night on that five
somewhere then I should be just winning
I mean I'm a pawn and his gank is also
not very secure so I thought should
should be should be able to win this
position yeah probably should be lost
and here I guess rook e1 was a very
strong move and after this probably the
game the game is just done if he takes
on e3 then the idea is I just promoted
the pawn and I was very careful here and
not to allow any sudden chance for him
and I guess it's just completely winning
in fact for me yeah so yeah so he I mean
once you want to pass the defense on a
pawn in my pieces really good so it
should be it should be should be an easy
win I calculated some tactics here of 96
actually after 96 I wasn't sure exactly
what I want to do
I mean 97 look looks really interesting
iFit takes then check
takes and yeah I'm up a pawn and I'm not
sure if you can take it if you can take
a nice sermon because then just like
rookie seven
even if Quincy three then I just plan to
take like Indy six although although it
probably would have been better chance
for him to go like 96 this after Bishop
g5 after Bishop g5 it's just completely
waiting for me because I'm a potent pawn
up and even in some cases when I give up
the pawn or a seven I'll just probably
have a median attack of the bishop
before so it doesn't doesn't really
matter that point a seven is actually
kind of insignificant at this point you
know I may even give it up and still
probably be winning so what was that
pawn obviously it's even easier yeah I
mean you play a few more moves but it
didn't really matter
yeah because the position is just
waiting yeah so you're a half point out
of first place so Cobian and then Yara
what is your mindset going into tomorrow
well I'm playing black and I'm playing
and so as a cobia but you're both
playing the Cubans actually tomorrow
yeah well I didn't know that I mean then
though they keep playing because of them
well I'll just try to play usual chess
like kind of soulless you know it's not
like I'm desperate to push for a win or
something you know I mean if I make a
draw at pros fine with me obviously
is it fair to say you'll at least be
keeping a pretty close eye on his game
no I don't really care okay
well there you go there's the chess
player right there yeah I mean whatever
happens happens I just have to play in
normal chest you know like yeah
all right you're on zero book thank you
for joining me best of luck tomorrow in
the final day of play let's take a look
going into the last day the standings
for group a the three Americans at the
top can still win group a if a Cobian
win
as black against cassada Perez he wins
outright it doesn't matter what the
other results are zero book has black
against Lazaro burrs own tomorrow he has
to at least force a playoff with a score
that is better than what a Cobian does
and finally for Jeffrey Zhang to even
have a chance he has to win as black
tomorrow and that means also that a
Cobian loses and that zero book doesn't
out score him in the event of a two or
three way tie we will have a playoff to
determine the undisputed winner a wonder
liang and christian korilla are the two
players who can still take group b a
wonder has white tomorrow against action
Chandra if a wonder wins then no doubt
about it he automatically wins the field
for korilla to win he has to score
better than a wonder does but korilla
has black against Alexander Lenderman
if a wonder drawers and korilla wins or
a wonder losses and korilla draws then
we will have a playoff at the end of the
day he almost clinched it today Group C
competitor Grandmaster Sam seve on the
sixteen-year-old phenom himself Sam
thank you for joining me today those
watching on Ches 24 and us chess champs
calm may have been like whoa Sam was
totally winning but you just analyzed
the game and maybe it wasn't exactly
what the engines on those sites said so
tell us what you thought about the game
and let's take a look at it so going to
the game I was pretty okay with the draw
and he chose the road solid line English
and I was really happy about it he
played a rare line and I didn't know it
but I think I've answered very well
later on I got a nice cushion an extra
pawn and I'm sorry I apologize I should
mention it you'd be a politician mano
shima-ya okay I got an extra pawn and it
was always closer to a draw you know
when end end positions of theoretical
truth so get into it he played a 94 now
I took the pawn it should be to where I
spent some time I can go back with the
solid position but I felt that I had
something more so Roxy for 22:26 rook e1
rook e8 at first it looks really
dangerous because it's Knight takes f6
92 opening the e-file but I think what
has everything under control
Black has his own things action Bishop
f8 and then black can detect 94 but if i
drugged you one and I put the
programming Bishop afraid so I think we
should take before with Matt babish
should be four and I couldn't find
anything concrete here because what
one-syllable ship takes b6 and then some
IDs with night except stick Bishop g5
looks really dangerous for black let's
say if I snatch the night off I was
looking at lines like this f5 we should
be 5 Guindy files Queenie 8 take take
take check Queen f7 13 Ricky a Famicom
of like 97 Ricky 8h 6 root dude and I
think works
winning after play Queen f6 that he
takes the pawn hit 77 he takes a 7 and
black who's going for draw here
there it also is like engage hate that
again Bishop takes Bishop take b6 it's
very dangerous
my main heroes root d8 with the idea of
checking on the 54 if he takes the
knight now I think I can take on the one
so I take on the one take on e4
yeah I picture coming off that should be
the you'd refer blood but I saw the
smoke we need to really nice geometric
geometrical idea why tracking metrics up
sticks and therefore I can't take you
books of night six of six absent on both
side I did not find a bit more fearful
luck maybe Queen assemble definitely
looks very dangerous
I chose Qing Fei I think this is a
really strong move the King leaves this
knowing pin on the a20 diagonal which
Bishop from smoothy files
yeah and all the tactical shots don't
seem to work here for example if Knight
takes f6 Bishop takes f6 Queenie six
rookie six um another shot was 92 but
now I just trade after Roxy to the most
importantly which was Bishop before
cutting of the rooks is met by Bishop
takes e4 you should take before Bishop
c5 now he has to take on c5 take on c5
and block starting rookie five close to
a new position for luck here if Queen
takes e4 Queen sixty four we end up in a
pawn up ending for black
so he played 93 which leads to a pointer
bending for black but what is quite
active and probably regained upon at
some point taketake there should be this
is a critical moment in my opinion
because I can either defend the pawn
with Ruby a or make a move like c6
cutting off the bishop but I decide to
sacrifice a pawn back and go for
activity with Bishop e5 painting game
scores exploit baton I have extra pawn
but he definitely has turned play with
ideas like 95 or b1 therefore it shows
this idea Bishop d6 takes takes check
move took my pawn and I paint in here he
plays rooks you want using two different
pins but it's not easy to take advantage
of this because every time I Rick moves
he has an ID like 91 okay maybe a four
first yeah you can't play 91 here
because after Bishop takes P to Ruby 491
dependent upon B to note that if you
place move like 91 take take Roxy to and
I give one rooks you want blacks
position looks really good would be one
next ships t2 I think I'm winning pawn
and then public again rooks you wanna
split you should be seven Bishop a6 so
it looks like weights hanging on by his
teeth and I can't find break through
here as hard as I tried at some point
I'm going to have to go Ruby c5 give my
Bishop for this tonight and take the
pawn be 5 and that's what happens so
rook c5 threatening metaphor check and
Bishop takes c3 yeah this is a critical
moment 5.94 looks and we were both in
time trouble here like two three minutes
each here of 94 let's say Bishop g4
check take I take the bishop and we
leave would be to get to an obstacle a
bishop ending what down upon which has
very good drawing chances the bishop
will come to you forward will play g4
and probably get an easy fortress so I
put h5 that's three now he's threatening
to play 94 because if it should be fun a
tick tick tick cake then you can
probably take on c7 so I finally took on
c3 each I put the rook I thought you
would take with the bishop and put the
bishop on d4 stop my coupon from rolling
but this was also okay
take take bishop C 1 C 5 H 3 I said good
winning chances in is something but it's
really easy to play for white just the
rook on c2 Bishop e3 King T to play G 4
at some point and I'm not sure how is
post progress here I put c4 rooks t2
will be 3 I spent some time on Ruby 3 I
think I was in mistake I should have
played rook c5 it should be through
statistics and add long or work g7
defending j7 fun with the idea of Knight
d5 and as a long-term pressure in
defending maybe I would win exactly I'd
like this I put up with her which is
more concrete move and now Bishop e3 if
I take the pawn we always get two
positions like this three versus three
with an extra pawn on the Queen side
which is theoretically drawn if white
knows it he knows it if nothing even if
you don't know it's pretty hard to
neglect I choose c3 the ship c5
she got a 92 for a 4 and I played 93
Brooks you won a sighs looks like I've
made a lot of progress with three pieces
on the third-ranked but after King BC -
King G - boys starting to take on a
three and then take out C - again
getting the three three with one outside
past pot on the Queen side yeah here I
didn't like the move I made I played g4
which exchanges two points and I had no
reason to do this I could have played a
move like Lucas III wish I'd paid
through Katie Lucas T - okay four and
played this on and on in this position
problem with the move g4 was after
exchanges this is much easier to hold
for white because the King goes to g2
and rook goes behind the pond and like
has no way to progress and when I try
bringing my king he just cuts me off
slippery pay sticks and you fire the
last finesse I take I took and this is
theoretical zero black guys know which
progress even though is of two points
and again manager shortly well very cool
Sam you are a full point ahead of alien
is Nick and tomorrow your game you play
white against roofing Lee the last time
you and we met in this tournament it was
a draw so the question is needing only
to score tomorrow only a half point will
win the field do you come in playing for
a win or come in playing for a draw yeah
I'm not sure I'll probably think about
that snake
that's it well maybe I'll talk to you
tomorrow as the champion of Group C as I
want to jinx anything but good luck Sam
let's take a look going into that very
last round the standings for the double
round-robin group C we're down to seven
and knees neck in Group C both players
have the white pieces tomorrow in their
respective games music has shook open
and seve on has roofing lis all Savion
has to do is draw and he is the group C
champion the only path to the group C
championship for Ely initiative is
persevere on Toulouse and Munich to win
that's the only way and then both
players will compete in a playoff it all
comes down to this tomorrow Wednesday
May 24 is the final day of play and we
will have playoffs if necessary who will
be the champions of groups a B and C
find out at a very special start time of
11 a.m. central see the move by move
live as it happens at chess 24 calm and
us chess champ calm